ثلاثه اخوه ولدان وبنت يفقدون البصله منذ
الصغر تتولى امهم رعايتهم في غياب والدهم
الذي يعمل بعيدا
يتوجه لاشقاء والثلاثه الى المدرسه كل
صباح في ظروف ليست سهله لا عليهم ولا على
والدتهم
الكبير نفسه
المدرسه داخل اتحاد المكفوفين بالخرطوم
بحري تعمل لمرحلتي الاساس والثانوي لكنها
تعاني نقصا حادا في وسائل التعليم وتطوير
مهارات المكفوفين فيها
يعني عاجزه تماما عن تغطيه كل الاحتياجات
بالنسبه للمكفوفين لانه ما في تسير
للاتحاد ما في اي جهه بتساعد في تحريك
النشاط بتاع الاتحاد
يتعلموا بعضهم مهارات يدويه لا تخلو من
ابداع
جيم
الى الحصول على مهنه لكسب الحياه
خيريه للمساعده في توفير الاحتياجات بما
فيها اكمال تشييد مبنى دراسيا يستفيد من
خدماته الطلاب والمكفوفون من جميع انحاء
السودان
وتمت تكمله البناء فيها سوف يكون حلمي
لوزاره التربيه والتعليم لانها سوف تستطيع
ان تستقبل كل الطلاب المكفوفين من كل بقاع
السودان سيبه اذا كان في مرحله الاساس
المرحله المتوسطه والمرحله الثانويه
في معهد النور لتعليم المكفوفين اطفال
يمارسون تفاصيل حياتهم في الظلام لكن
بصيرتهم تنير لهم الطريق
[موسيقى]